Dominic masa is Augusta green jackets
pitcher and a newfound fame I don't
think he was certainly looking for this
kind of fame but he gave up a home run
to Tim Tebow Tim's first at-bat in the
minor leagues Thursday night and Dominic
is kind enough to join us first of all
how do you feel today I'm just going to
the field right now and I'm excited to
get my work in today how many phone
calls text messages voicemails did you
get were they friends now friends giving
you grief or what did they say to you
yeah I mean a little bit of both so sent
over hashtag that's mean-spirited there
take me through last night
how big a crowd was their attendance was
so and is that no that's not normal
last year when I played at Columbia
they'd normally brought in around five
six thousand okay it wasn't it wasn't
too out of the ordinary for that I would
say what was that my larger than normal
though what was the scouting report on
team oh really I didn't have one but I
should have established inside better to
him just because from what I had heard
it was yet a little bit slower bat but
he does have he's a strong guy so he
could get around on one and what did you
throw many hen out
I missed my spot I hit I throw that ball
away which he made a great swing on and
I have my job to UM but you're not a
you're not a guy who's gonna throw 95
right so you have to you have to spot if
you'd miss your spots you can get in
trouble yeah what did you know going in
mix it up because I don't have about 95
and when the ball went over when they
signal homerun would you think I mean I
just was focused on the next hitter to
be honest and then after the inning I
kind of thought about it some guys in
the dugout and stuff were joking around
with me and then just kind of went on
from there but it was it's kind of
unbelievable that his first maybe he did
it all not there's things that are
magical that happened around him you
know I don't think he's a major leaguer
but you know the fact that he's down
there trying at age what 29 and it's
still pretty impressive right now we're
talking to Dominik maza the Augusta
green jackets pitcher he's drafted by
the Giants 22nd round out of UC Santa
Barbara in 2015 but also prior to that
you were in the Remax long drive contest
so you were in it at age 16 yeah and you
finished runner-up but do you want you
didn't want to be a golfer baseball's
my number one passion
for right now and if for some reason
baseball has to come to an end in my
life then I definitely have a strong
passion for golf as well which I will
start picking up again well you play for
the Augusta green jackets have you
played Augusta yet if you went over to
Augusta right now could you out drive
everybody
I could probably out drive them but keep
it in the fairway what's tougher to
control a drive or a pitch it definitely
depends on the day but uh I'd say a
drive if you're hitting it 400 yards
well hey have fun with it you know
I know that people are gonna rough you
up a little bit but have fun with it I
think the more you embrace it the less
they'll rough you up about it and hey
you got you got burned in it that's part
of being a pitcher but you're 22 yeah
you got a long life ahead of you so
enjoy it you got some publicity
hopefully you get some good publicity
here soon Dominic Dominic Mazda the
Augusta green jackets pitcher gave up
the home run to Tim Tebow the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience